Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my new guardians of the
galaxy 3 video James Gunn just made a
bunch of big announcements Vin Diesel
revealed a bunch of big details we got
to break it down there's a whole bunch
of Easter eggs Adam warlock what's going
on with rocket what's going on with
alpha Groot
so if you're new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the Easter egg
videos we're doing an Amazon giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave all your
predictions for guardians 3 on the video
so we'll just go down the list here
starting with number 5 Guardians 3 will
take place after the events of Thor
technically but originally it was
written to take place before Thor for
love and thunder if you don't remember
before it was cancelled it was actually
supposed to come out July 20 2008
guardians 3 this year but then when they
cancelled that they took it off the
schedule as their Marvel phase 4 plans
changed they decided to do Thor for love
and thunder is the Mighty Thor storyline
they still had that hanging plot teaser
at the end of Avengers endgame with fat
Thor leaving with the guardians
originally they would have resolved that
at the beginning of guardians 3 I just
posted a big video on Thor for Taika
Waititi to d'vega livestream revealing a
bunch of details concept art and teasers
for the movie so I'll link that at the
end of this but he also revealed that
Thor is not going to be fat Thor during
Thor for love and thunder in the
guardians will cameo at the beginning of
Thor 4 so for there's a small time jump
between the end of Avengers endgame in
the beginning of guardians 3 and Thor 4
but think about the timeline this way
even after they delayed guardians 3
James Gunn said that they didn't have
any big plans to change the story and so
it was written to take place before Thor
4 so early prediction what they'll do
for guardians 3 is just edit at the
beginning just a little bit so that Thor
when he cameos at the beginning of that
movie they just referenced the events of
Thor 4 instead of doing things the other
way around and having a Thor 4 teaser at
the end of guardians 3 as they probably
would have originally done and now
because the first cameo the Guardians
cameo is happening at the beginning of
Thor 4 it'll be Taika Waititi shooting
that scene so it'll be whatever his idea
is for the Guardians inside Thor 4 in
presumably James Gunn will just give him
some notes for how he's going to leave
the guardians so that things make sense
when guardians 3 picks up so just based
on what they're saying it sounds like
guardian
three will take place pretty close in
the timeline to Thor 4 even though
guardians three won't be released till
at least 2022 or 2023 they're getting
real weird with the timeline during
Marvel phase four so not all the movies
take place one right after the other
even though the release schedule is one
right after the other they did the same
thing for guardians of the galaxy to
where it takes place firmly in the
middle of Marvel phase three but it only
takes place in the timeline a couple
months after the events of guardians one
number three addressing the alpha Groot
in the room so Vin Diesel did a bunch of
interviews for his bloodshot movie
earlier this year and that was when he
revealed all these big spoilers and
details for guardians three and Thor
four this is the clip of him mentioning Alpha Groot.
Thor will also...the director
talked to me about how Thor will
incorporate some of the guardians of the
galaxy which would be very interesting
nobody knows but maybe I shouldn't have
said anything but I only have two words
about that character and it is
Alpha Groot.
So you all ask, what is Alpha Groot?
It sounds like the craziest biggest most awesome version of Groot.
well James Gunn actually piped up on
Twitter about this because people were
asking him what does Vin Diesel mean
alpha Groot DISA sounds crazy what's
going on you could kind of feel that
James Gunn was a little upset by this
because he doesn't want to give anything
away he wrote the script a long time ago
and like I said they're not changing the
script so whatever is happening to groot
during the movie it's been decided a
long time ago but it sounds like Vin
Diesel actually did give something real
away so he's just playing coy saying I
have no idea what he's talking about
maybe he just means the most awesome
version of Groot obviously what they're
referring to is the next evolution of
Groot
what is his final boss form going to be
Vin Diesel is referring to it as alpha
guru so I'm assuming it's going to be an
even more spectacular version of GRU
than what we saw in guardians one when
he was full-sized the thing about his
species is that they don't stop growing
he can keep growing
they changed him a little bit from the
comics and the way his powers work so
what James Gunn did when we got to
guardians 2 in dancing baby Groot
started growing up and we have teenage
group now is that he said that's closer
to being groots
offspring instead of being just a
regrowth of the original Groot to
himself like it is in the comics in the
comics if GRU gets blown up
can regrow his entire body from a single
twig so you put him in a planted pot and
you grow him back he it's the same
version of Groot but apparently that's
not the case in the movies but the way
James Gunn's talked about it earlier
rocket and Groot back story are the two
most important things for the guardians
of the galaxy three story obviously you
had the story of Peter quill looking for
the younger version of Gamora from 2014
she's still running around she didn't
have any of that character development
she had no attachment emotional or
otherwise to Peter quill so she just
took off when the battle was over nebula
is probably going to be the one to win
her over and it's going to be be more about
their sisterly bond and maybe Peter
quill will get some play by the end of
the movie maybe he'll start the winner
over slowly but really it's more about
nebula and Gamora storyline so when
James Gunn was talking about the movie on
Twitter he was talking about how
important Rockets past trauma
confronting that in the scars on his
back what happened to him how he was
created is going to be to the story of
guardians 3 so think about the guardians
movies this way each of the movies has
had some sort of confrontation with the
father figure like the first movie you
have Santos as the father figure in
guardians 2 yet Peter quill confronting
his father ego the Living Planet so
because so much of guardians 3 story is
going to turn on Rockets backstory and
Groot as well it sounds like they'll be
confronting rockets quote-unquote father
if you want to call him that the person
that created Rocket Raccoon that'll
probably wind up being the main villain
of the film even though we do have Adam
warlock so don't worry Adam warlock as
part of my video here but he's probably
not going to be the main villain they're
actually some clues about who created
Rocket Raccoon in the movies this is
James Gunn's quote right after guardians
2 came out when he was talking about the
future of the characters in the MCU he
said we're going to learn more about
where Rocket comes from in the coming
sagas it'll be a little bit different
from the comics we already know a lot
about where he came from
it's a little bit more horrible than it
is in the comics when you come down to
it we will learn more about that we know
that Rocket comes from half world we got
them in the lineup during guardians 1
that's confirmed that's where he comes
from in the comics but they're going to
do a different version of his backstory
in the movies James Gunn is known for
doing really weird really deep cut
comic-book characters so who created
Rocket Raccoon in the MCU well there's a
really big Easter Egg for it during
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 after the
escape that sovereign fleet at the
beginning of the movie in namely ego the
planet that they land on is called burr
hurt which is an anagram of Herbert the
high evolutionary's real name Herbert
Edgar Windham who also appeared for the
first time in the Thor comics so now you
can kind of see the fun of including
Thor in a cameo during guardians 3 one
of his trademark things that he does in
the classic comics is evolving animals
into humanoids that could walk around
and talk just like rocket racoon so just
remember that James Gunn said that
Rockets origin in the movies is going to
be different from the comic book story
it'll be way darker so because each of
these guardians movies is about the
Guardians confronting their past trauma
head-on the way Peter quill did with
guardians 2 with ego the Living Planet
confronting his trauma over the death of
his mother Groot sacrificing himself in
the first movie it sounds like Rockets
going to be confronting his past trauma
in his creation through this High
Evolutionary villain they got into that
a little bit during guardians 2 when
yondu was giving in the business I
understand why you're such an assh*le to
everyone else because I used to be just
like you it was mostly about them
projecting their trauma on to the rest
of the people around them so everyone
post your high evolutionary theories in
the comments below
James Gunn did meet with Mark Hamill a
couple years ago about doing a project
together now Mark Hamill says that he
hasn't been offered a role in a Marvel
film but I think he would be a great
version of the High Evolutionary if they
want to do that then obviously number
one Adam warlock hatching from his
chrysalis cocoon in the sovereign's
setting into the task of destroying the
guardians of the galaxy until they're
able to win him over and it becomes a
big plan as original comic book debut if
you're not a big Marvel comic book
reader Adam warlock was created to be a
weapon by this super advanced race
eventually he turned into something of a
space Jesus that's kind of the way they
used him for a long time in the comics
my assumption is is the MCU version of
Adam warlock will be a little bit
different with a lot of Easter eggs and
references to his comic book origin in
the same way that all the other guardian
characters are different from their
comic book versions but as they teased
in the guardians of the galaxy 2
post-credits scene he is created to be a
perfect being it's a little bit like
Ultron creating vision to be a perfect
being I do like the idea of Adam warlock
eventually joining the guardians team
like he did in the comics but I'm not
totally sure
long-term what Marvel's plans are for
the Guardians characters because Chris
Pratt said that he wants to stick around
and be in more Marvel movies and there
will be more space based movies like
Nova the Captain Marvel sequels Thor
love and thunder is the first time that
they've done a fourth movie for a big
franchise like that that's not an
Avengers movie but James Gunn did say
the guardians 3 is the end of the arc
over these three films that he's done
for these characters so don't be
surprised if they cycle the guardians
roster at the end of guardians 3 somehow
everyone let me know in the comments
what do you want them to do with the
Guardians team if they don't do
guardians for which other movie do you
want them to show up in next if you
didn't see my last video I'm also in the
middle of an Avengers infinity saga
re-watched video series where I go
through each of the movies in the MCU
pointing out the big Marvel phase for
Easter eggs that we missed the first
time my next video for that will be for
Incredible Hulk you can click here for
the beginning for my Iron Man video as
part of that series and click here for
that brand new Thor 4 teaser breakdown
and Marvel announcement thank you so
much for watching everyone stays safe
I'll see you guys tonight!